So let's take a look at the use of operators to
support Range Queries. Let me show you what I mean. MongoDB
provides several inequality operators that enable us to perform this type
of query. The inequality operators we may use include greater than,
less than, greater than or equal to, less than or equal
to, or not equal to. There are also a couple that
are designed for querying array fields. We'll talk about those in
a later lesson. Now let's look at some queries against our cities
collection that provide examples of using inequality operators. Okay.
So imagine that we want to query for all
cities with the population greater than a quarter million.
Instead of specifying an exact number here, as the value
for our query document, which is going to be passed
to find here, or instead going to use the greater
than operator and the value of population in a
query document it's going to be a sub document using
that operator. We can specify a more constrained range
for a query like this using an additional operator.
Now this example is very similar to what we
just looked at, the only difference being that in the
value for population in our query document we're specifying
an additional operator of less than or equal to 500,000.
Thus defining a more constrained range for this query
here. Now this type of range based query works across
many different data types. We can do something
similar for strings. So here, the semantics of this
range are give us all city names that begin
with x. Let's go ahead and run this code.
And here we can see that in the results we
get back. Looks like we're getting back cities that just begin
with the letter X. Total match of 22 cities out of
the 20,000 or so that are in this collection. Okay, let's
look at our code again. We can also do this
type of query against dates. Here we're specifying a Python date
as the lower and upper bound, and so here we're looking
for all cities that have a founding date sometime in the
year 1837. And actually, to be precise here, we should really have
this be greater than or equal to. Okay, now let's run this.
Okay, and we get three cities that match. We can see that the founding date here
seems to be within range, as it is here, and also here, for the city of
Chicago. Finally, we can also do things like
use the not equals operator to for example
in this case, find all cities with a
country that's not equal to the United States.